- talking about title players in general
and we obviously have already prefaced
the fact that we've seen record numbers
in terms of people playing online one of
the shocking things that happened over
this last month was that we also saw a
record number of title players sign up
meaning the way a title player signs up
on our site just just so you know the
process is they sign up they have to
send them a selfie of them with a date
and says chest comm on it so it's a
selfie so we know it's them along with a
picture of their passport or some sort
of ID right and you'll be surprised how
many people try to photoshop and and get
a free diamond membership as the title
player we got to write a blog about that
one day and show the best photo shops of
people trying to do identity theft I'm
legit someone make a note about that
place and so title players have been
signing up in the masses as well and
that's always shocking to us because you
would think like on all the title
players already playing online but the
chess world is so huge and the chess
world's legacy has been beyond all of us
online here right they've the chess
world has been around before chess calm
exists and it'll be around long after
the internet goes down when we all go
dark and John Connor takes over and
leads us to freedom right I mean chess
has been around forever and so the
amount of title players signing up has
also been amazing a lot of them have
been taking advantage of the offerings
we have we turned our title Tuesdays
into a weekly thing you know to give
back even more we'll watch it and we're
launching the premium arena we increase
the prize funds entitled Tuesday as you
saw so not only do we increase the prize
fund but it's now weekly instead of
monthly and then not just the first
Tuesday but every Tuesday there's more
coming in terms of events that I have
been sworn to secret let's see on some
of those so I'm not gonna say it yet but
we have plans to increase our offering
overall and and things that have already
existed but maybe unifying and making
them bigger badder and greater bigger
better faster stronger Thank You doc
funk but there's also been a lot of
title players who have experienced the
pandemic if you will of online cheating
and and forgive me if that's an
inappropriate term right now but I would
argue that we've been facing our own
kind of pandemic and before I before I
start talking about that I want to bring
up an open letter that was sent to chess
comm we threw this on our own template
but this was a Word document that was
sent to us by international master it
was forwarded to us by big large Obama
international master but it was signed
by many title players including some
the world's best and to be quite honest
a few names that maybe maybe they're
more familiar with our fair play process
than some of their peers know if that's
if that's the most appropriate way I can
say that about some of the names on
there and for those listening but what I
want to highlight is that there's a lot
on that list that we're actually already
doing that people don't know I know that
that's not a totally legible thing for
you but in my effort to be totally open
and address this in a way that I hope
gets shared and I hope people talk about
I hope the criticism and questions come
they always do anyway so I don't need to
hope for it but I also hope that there's
maybe some understanding and insight
into some things we haven't shared
before and that's what we're gonna start
doing now so before I dive in to our
fair play maraca ting I just want to be
totally open here I'm a little nervous
about this and I don't know why I don't
get nervous that often anymore but I
suddenly felt myself getting the
butterflies and I was once told by
somebody whenever you're nervous just
say so so Danny's a little nervous right
now and not because not because anything
that I'm gonna talk about is something
I'm not supposed to talk about I hope
not
and reveal too much of what we do but
because the truth is what I'm about to
talk about is near and dear in the
hearts of a lot of personal friends of
mine I have I have fielded a lot of very
tough phone calls and emails over the
last couple weeks and we are gonna
follow up today's show with an open
letter to the global chess community and
I'm gonna tell you that right before
this show I received a phone call from a
dear friend who acknowledged to me that
his student had cheated and admitted and
asked me what the process was for his
second chance last week I dealt with
more high profile closures in terms of
cheating things that were happening that
would that would shock you we have
closed three north of 2600 GM's and many
people below that over the last week and
we made some breakthroughs I want to
come back to the March article that we
talked about and talk about what I I met
with that I'm not we are not going to
get into names so if those of you start
screaming in chat and Contra we we have
been publicly outed by some people who
publicly outed themselves for cheating
because they decided they would take the
the crying wolf approach and and and
either call us liars or threatened
suits and lawsuits and those sort of
things and some of you who are old
school members here in the online chess
community know who I'm talking about
people that have said directly or
accused us of lying and threatened
lawsuits and I can say that nothing
became of that and so you can do the
math we have been taking a lot of heat
by that open letter from tidal players
and in some cases we have been
specifically called out for not acting
fast enough I'm still not going to talk
about names but what I'm gonna say is
this the improvements we made in terms
of the the added the added sheet
detection here have recently led to some
to some breakthroughs that well we will
continue to honor our promise of acting
conservatively if anyone in chat has a
link if you would to our to our fair
play in cheating on chess comm that has
our testimonials from guys like Maxime
Vasya the growl of Eric Hanson John
Bartholomew people that we have invited
to see under the hood and have given us
their endorsement you're also going to
see a link there to a letter from a head
of Statistics at Harvard that says that
chefs calm has been audited and they as
much as chess calm can as long as as
much as smoking can be proven to cause
cancer chess calms cheating catches
cheaters but also apps conservatively
and the reason that's important to us is
because as much as it always feels like
we need to act in the moment I got I
gotta be totally honest and give news I
have zero interest in defaming or
destroying the reputation of any title
player or human being on the planet and
our our policies operate in that we may
be its sometimes criticized for acting
too slowly I'm aware that our company
might lose many PR battles along the way
of being seen as acting too slow but you
will know that when we pull the trigger
not only are we ready to go to court but
also we're not we're not looking back
despite threats and things that have
come our way you can also be sure that
we're gonna continue to win the war
while losing many battles in the sense
that we're not gonna stop investing in
creating opportunities for professionals
online where if anything we're
increasing it and we're not doing it in
in one-off kind of splash big prize
funds we're doing it every week and
giving every title player an opportunity
to do something not just with streaming
not just with title Tuesdays but with
other Grand Prix series we have coming
again and I won't say more Nick don't
worry but I'm getting into it because
this isn't about me defending its open
letter this is about
I want to start diving into you I'm
gonna tell you specifically as I can
what it is that we do is that this is a
very difficult topic because when you
close a young talented you know person
of any country who may actually be a
very strong player but it may be of
given in to water cooler talk and people
saying don't worry chess calm can't
catch you anyway they were wrong when
you when you close a title player who
even if we want a morally judge why they
did it might literally be fighting to
feed his family because of what's
happening with cope in nineteen or
because of other lack of opportunities
it's not right and we do act but we also
don't judge and create a second chance
opportunity with with with suspensions
require for prize events and things like
that because of that when you when you
close anybody even if they're just a
regular member without a reputation in
the chess community you don't know what
anybody's dealing with their demons in
their life right be kind because you
can't rewind my mom always used to say
that and the point is be kind because
you don't know what other people dealing
with and that is the policy we operate
so people who want to judge usually
behind an anonymous veil that we're
doing a wrong thing I want you to know
we're doing the right thing and we're
acting and we're closing people for for
for violations and when we do it's not
easy for anybody and sometimes it leads
to the kind of heartfelt conversations
that are very difficult to deal with
between a parent talking about a child
who came clean or like I said a friend
of mine with a student or a fellow title
player and so what is it so that's so
I've gotten my nerves out of the way I
want you to know like this is a very
sensitive issue but we're not dumb to it
and and with some of the algorithms
we've broken through with recently we
are about to close more title players
than we ever have before and we every
everybody gets a review and so that's
some of the process we're getting into
but I want to describe to everybody
before we invite the invite the option
that we're going to at the end of the
show to understand a little more about
what we do so here are some of the
things that people who have signed our
NDA and taken that course guys like John
Bartholomew and others and people that
know what we do they know even more than
the high-level points I'm going to give
you but I'm gonna describe as best I can
so chest out comes fair play process
what is it that we do so our team of
fair play professionals we use
statistical methods and the reason I
want to emphasize that first is to
always remind you that
no matter what it looks like we are
never reacting to a mob mentality we are
acting with DNA evidence in terms of the
blueprint of the game so that we could
stand behind this legally in March we we
reviewed more than 90 million that's
actually that's actually getting into
the record levels of how many games and
the Fair Play team has been working
overtime to date in March including some
that we received we have received more
than 300 written confessions from tidal
players including grandmasters including
grandmasters north of 2600 and I won't
get into more specifics than that so
despite the public outcry as you might
hear despite people being frustrated at
times that we acted too slowly despite
even the very very few cases and again
always in total transparency on state of
chess calm and one that was on reddit
recently I would argue that the fact
that we were able to acknowledge that we
were wrong about a specific case speaks
more highly to the fact that you should
trust us when we hold though our guns
and don't reopen somebody if anything
acknowledging the very very few times
we've been wrong over the last nine ten
years might speak more truthfully and
highlight to the fact that we are
ultimately still humble we don't claim
to be perfect we just claim to be doing
our best and if we mess up and a proper
review is given you will be given a
chance at a second chance and you will
be reopened hopefully that speaks more
truthfully to the fact of what you can
us discern the same manual review and
appeal process is given to anybody who
challenges us and if we don't reopen
them what does that say and then coming
back there to our training processes on
the on our Fairplay bullet points there
let's bring that up for everybody again
our training process is that not only
are we working within within the
internal group that we have that that
works on this stuff but we also are
working with top agencies so I I jumped
ahead a little bit to talk about the
internal training process we have for
the current team so the current team
recently expanded is of nine full-time
team members I'm only listening to
full-time team members I am not
listening part time may be overseas who
were not allowed to call full time maybe
maybe you know salary and just I'm
listing full-time people who work to
improve algorithms around the clock to
protect the experience of our members on
chess calm and to title players who are
who are full-time manual review ex
and then many others that contribute
including yourself yourself yeah you you
could no yours truly and Grand Master
Robert Hess as far as people that are in
the inner circle of knowing and in
reviewing this stuff and have been
improving our own review of not just
looking at what the data what the DNA is
telling us and what the actual chess is
telling us for years during events and
this is this is back to the open letter
that was said and now I'm getting into
it the open letter addressed pretty
directly some suggestions but it doesn't
know is that we're actually already
doing the majority of that the open
letter even acknowledges and I'm
speaking to the title players who signed
it but within a reasonable view of
what's possible to put people on camera
the open letter acknowledged in a title
Tuesday with more than a thousand people
how could we reasonably be expected to
put everybody on camera one that would
hardly be fair to them a lot of people
have slow internet right and if you know
there's you know no reason I mean it
should be random it shouldn't just be we
pluck people to put them on camera right
that would be profiling and but we do
work with people not only in terms of
getting them on camera requiring a view
of their room asking about their device
asking if they're alone also we get
screen share in cases and I'm gonna say
that there have been cases where people
were asked to do this and they
immediately quit without naming names
you should know that as a title player
community you should also know that the
players are as I said only they selected
for random observation but yes also if a
player has been proven to not cooperate
they will then essentially be profile
but not profile they will be asked to
say okay well it was random at first but
now that you won't cooperate you're not
allowed to compete again until you're
able to do this this way the way we want
it so a lot of people don't know we are
doing that in addition to the to the
very strong grandmasters and title
players we've been closing over the last
month and we're working all the time not
just with top agencies but with audits
we talked about the written letter we
have from a head of Statistics at
Harvard but we have others and and we
have been audited and we are continuing
to get training we're taking notes from
what other eSports industries do in
terms of how they Proctor people there
is literally almost nothing that gets
more of an investment and is leading to
breakthroughs all the time then you know
as far as a back-end to
right yes we're working on a new board
and there's a lot of developers on that
and we invest in things you can see that
our public facing but it is beyond to
say a very serious focus for us and so
the one of the reasons we're able to do
what we do and this is gonna be the last
thing I'm going to leave you with before
we take a break and hopefully get into
some of your questions why why do we
claim to be doing as good of a job as we
again I don't want to say we're claiming
to be doing a good job or the best job I
think we're doing a great job within the
means and investment that we can measure
and I think we can always do better but
the main thing we're doing is trying to
prepare to to not just deal with
individual cases but our goal in our
investment is to say the biggest pie in
this guy thing is to eventually kind of
end cheating at least in terms of title
player events a new person coming along
who cheats one time or people who you
know gets is given to temptation
randomly we obviously closed accounts in
that realm of the thousands every month
right but we do believe that there is a
potential future where in the process of
us losing some PR battles and doing that
but doing things privately and
conservatively not in the open public
way that some people would love to do
and scream cry crying wolf the truth is
over time less and less cheaters will be
playing in our events because those who
have tried to slander us and threaten
Zeus but then not they're not playing
anymore
people that won't admit they're not
playing anymore in our events and people
that did had to serve in some cases
multi-year bans before they were given a
second chance and then are forever
proctored even close even more closely
as they should be and we do not operate
and a third chance opportunity we
operate in a second chance opportunity
and the third time is a banned for life
and does that mean that that we're gonna
start publicly saying names to scare
other people I don't believe in that
form of capital punishment because I
don't believe it's right to slander or
defame a particular individual in order
to make a point to others but I will say
we do believe that over time as as
people start to know things and know and
know who and is not involved in the
things is that we can play a capital
punishment game that people will be more
scared and part of my goal of this and
telling my personal stories that I said
made me nervous
you know the the the friends and the
kids and the other title players is to
hopefully address this head-on and let
people know that if you are told that
we're not catching cheaters you're wrong
and I'm asking you to not do it and you
should know that again you're right that
everyone is right that we might act
conservatively in a way that gets people
frustrated on an individual event level
but we're not going to stop creating
opportunities and events for those
players who are frustrated they can rest
assured in that and the moment we have
enough to close it will be closed and
they will not come back without the
promise that they'll be clean to you
forevermore and never have a second
chance again if they go if they if they
cheat again or they won't be playing on
the site and our hope is that rumors do
spread just privately in the sense that
don't don't do it right it's wrong and
again no Martin no matter the level the
auto band features that we made that was
part of the sheet detection logic I
guess I forgot to say that Girard head
of sheet detection wanted me to do that
in the sense that we are now closing we
had one of their algorithmic
breakthroughs as we've been able to
start closing with certainty people
might say like when you say you're now
closing a thousand more accounts every
week aren't you saying Danny that was a
thousand cheaters that you weren't
getting to week before I am kind of
saying that but we're also getting
40,000 new accounts a day sometimes
repeat and you can read that what I'm
saying the other way in saying we
weren't closing those accounts because
we weren't sure that means the algorithm
breakthroughs we have have made him now
now we're closing a thousand more that
we'd be ready to go to court over and
that hopefully inspires a little bit of
confidence so again I'm here to both
acknowledge the mistakes that we have
been conservative at times and cheaters
have gotten away with it for longer than
I would have liked I said it and it's
true we have also openly acknowledged at
times where we've made mistakes and let
them back I hope you see that as a
testament to the integrity of what we're
doing and that we're willing to be wrong
despite the rumors and not a testament
that were that we're doing this the
wrong way if you consider how many of
them are being closed given reviewed and
not being given a chance back and then
also we're not going to stop investing
in the prizes that we are and the open
letter you sent title players has been
received and everybody who's considering
playing in the premium arena you should
know that it's even easier for us to
catch cheaters who are not by definition
having dedicated their life to the game
and they're supposed to match up with
engines as
that my way of scaring you you're darn
right it is please don't cheat we're
going to catch you and we're going to
catch you faster than you think and
you're going to lose out on the legal
rights to have your account which you
agree to when you signed up so we're
saying all this in the in the essence to
say we love you we do this we're very
fortunate to be where we are to have the
domain name we do to have the model we
do to have the team we have frankly the
people we have the love and our
investing and what we are and we are we
are seeing the kind of trajectory that
hopefully changes the chess world for
all of us forever but it has also led to
this unfortunate pandemic where young
people and and I and I'll even share
that it was said by it by a
psychological expert and I've observed
this behavior from other people that you
know during kovat people have been doing
some silly things at times it maybe it
has led to some idle Minds doing things
they wouldn't otherwise but we're
catching everybody we're acting and
we're not gonna stop investing in it and
hopefully you take this as our as our
word to know that I'm not we're not
claiming to be to be not even close if I
told you amount of things we'd like to
break through so that we know we can
catch cheaters not just in games but in
moves we are working on it all the time
with our with our with our awesome
awesome team but we're also not going to
stop in the process of investing along
the way even when we know sometimes we
act more conservatively than you would
like but at least you can know when we
do close we're not going to look back
and we have your back and so on that
note there's been a lot of questions
here I understand that I'm gonna have to
continue to answer for some of the
things that have been said and our mod
team have been pulling it so I hope that
I hope that you hear the message it's
going to be followed by a message sent
out to all of our members today and we
hope that those who are looking for
amnesty which is going to be offered
which is an acknowledgment before our
algorithmic breakthroughs start catching
everyone even faster that you might even
take that opportunity in the sense that
we do give people a second chance anyway
when they when they admit so to us out
offering amnesty is not really any
different than that it's just allowing
you to be more proactive if that's
something you want so that's something
we're gonna be doing with today's state
of just calm show so spoiler alert
that's a big news that we're gonna be
sending out